[THEME MUSIC]
SHANE GLASS: So we'll talk
about public datasets today.
So my name is Shane Glass.
I'm the program manager for
the Google Cloud public dataset
program.
I've got a couple
esteemed colleagues
that will be joining me here
later on stage in a minute.
So we're going to talk about
accessing and analyzing
large scale public
datasets in Google Cloud.
So here's today's speakers.
You can see the one on the left.
That's obviously the one
with the great jokes.
That's me.
And then the other two
gentlemen joining me
is Felipe Hoffa, one of
our developer advocates,
and Dr. Ed Kearns,
the Chief Data
Officer for the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration.
So I want to start with a
quote, and this is from--
this is from Fei-Fei Li
from last year at an Next.
I would have loved to
record her this year,
but I didn't know what her
keynote was going to be.
So I'm using last year's quote.
But it says, we need to scale--
"What we need is a more
scalable and effective way
to democratize data
for data scientists."
And I love this quote because
it is such a dead on description
of what our program
is looking to do,
the Google Cloud public
dataset program, and that's
working with public dataset
providers like NOAA,
and like NIH with the
partnership that was announced
earlier this week, to host
copies of their high value,
high demand datasets
on our cloud
to reduce the burden
for data scientists
and to make their
workflows easier,
to help them get to
where they need to be.
I mean, we're talking
about eliminating barriers
to entry for things like
basic utilization of data
and being able to open
up these really, really
valuable datasets
to users who come
from nontraditional partners--
from nontraditional
backgrounds, excuse me.
So how do we do that?
Well, we load them
into some of our tools.
We curate the datasets,
and we can dive into this
a little later.
But it's about making data
available to everybody.
You don't have to know where
to go, what to look for,
or what you're trying to find
before you have to find it.
So a little bit about myself--
if you were at Next last year,
and you have an exceptionally
good memory, then you know
that I was not the one giving
this presentation last year.
So I am the public
datasets program manager.
I joined Google in
April of this year,
coming over from NOAA where
I managed the Big Data
project before this.
And to answer that
question up front,
no, I do not know when the
next hurricane is going to hit.
Ed might.
You can ask Ed later.
And my background is
in data analytics,
and so I come into this
space from a little bit
of a perspective,
but I come at it
with the understanding
of that it
can be really, really difficult
to access and find open data.
When I was working
my master's degree,
I very distinctly remember that
the biggest frustration I had
wasn't learning Python.
It wasn't learning R. It
wasn't visualizing data.
That was actually a lot of fun.
It was finding open datasets
to do all these things on.
And that was a huge
frustration for me,
and it's made me really
passionate about open data.
And so that's one of the
reasons I wanted to come over,
and I want to make
these data more
democratized for our users.
So currently in
the program now, we
have a little over 90 datasets,
somewhere between 90 and 100.
And you can see the typical
scattershot-- it's not really
a session at Next if you
don't have a scattershot
of other people's logos.
So you'll see,
these are primarily
government agencies--
some states, some cities,
some local.
But what you're
really seeing here
is a list of the public
dataset providers whose data
we're hosting.
And these are onboarded
and maintained by Googlers
with inputting
guidance, of course,
from the subject matter experts
that are the data providers.
And what this really means
is that it's not just
a random collection of data
that someone sticks in an object
store and never looks at again.
There is a Googler going in
and discovering, finding,
downloading, extracting,
transforming, curating,
and maintaining these datasets.
And we think that provides
a better user experience
than other public
dataset programs,
because we are putting the
effort in and the time in
and our expertise
in the engineering
to bring these datasets to you.
And so we work closely
with these providers
to make sure that we understand
what the best practices are
for them, and that we
can describe the metadata
as properly as possible.
So we'll just go over some
really high level numbers
that sound really
impressive, and you guys can
decide if they mean anything.
So we've had, in BigQuery
alone, since Next of 2017--
so approximately one year ago--
we have had more than
80 petabytes queried,
and I'm seeing here from Chad
that that number is actually
higher than the
last time I looked,
which was about a week ago.
So that number is
probably closer to 90
now actually, so 90
petabyte-- higher than 90.
Do I hear 95, 95?
Do I hear 95?
100, 100, 100?
OK, so I'm way off.
So this is what
I saw from-- this
was a small sample of the
datasets I was looking at,
and I probably didn't
extrapolate this
as accurately as I could have.
But yeah, so a lot.
And so that's really
the answer there,
is people are using
a lot of public data.
But it's in BigQuery.
Now, hang on because
the public data we get
doesn't always come in a CSV,
or it doesn't come pre-loaded
in a BigQuery table, right?
And that's what I talked
about earlier, where
there are Googlers that
are building pipelines.
And they're extracting
this data into BigQuery
because it's an
easy SQL serverless
implementation that you
could come in and build
on top of right away.
And one of the really exciting
announcements from this week
is the BigQuery machine
learning introduction
that allows you to go on
and build machine learning
applications on top
of your SQL queries
using declarative statements.
So we have more
than 2,000 tables
in BigQuery for public
datasets with more than 42
billion rows--
yes, I did count each
of them individually.
Thank you for asking--
and more than 5,000
distinct users per week.
And this is a
number we're really
excited about because
if one user is querying
80 petabytes of
data, that's great,
but it doesn't necessarily
mean that we're not necessarily
democratizing that data
for the broader community.
But to see that volume number
grow with the number of users
and with the number of
distinct projects, that's
really exciting for us
because what that means
is that we're improving
the access for users.
We're making it easier for
users who may or may not
have been data users
in the past to come in
and leverage this data.
But it's not just BigQuery.
We have public data also in
GCS, so Google Cloud Storage.
We have more than three
petabytes of data there.
That includes things
like radar imagery,
so we have weather radar imagery
going back to 1991, all the way
until about 15 minutes ago.
And then we have
satellite imagery
as well from the Geostationary
Environmental Satellite 16,
so GOES-16.
It's a meteorological
satellite that
orbits over the same point
in the Earth at all times,
and that's all I know
about satellites.
But it is a high resolution,
both in space and time,
for imagery, and it
provides us with the ability
to better understand weather
patterns as they're unfolding.
We have the archive of that
going back to last year
as well, when it
became available.
So it's a quick overview
of Google BigQuery.
For those of you that aren't
familiar, I mentioned earlier,
it's a serverless
data warehouse that's
built to support
big data analysis.
Felipe has got some great
demos on BigQuery coming up,
but the one thing
I want to hit on
is that you don't have to worry
about developing or managing
or building the infrastructure.
It's already built.
All you have to do
is put your data in BigQuery
and write your SQL statements
on top of it.
And it scales
seamlessly and allows
you to share your
analysis very easily.
So there's a free tier for
storage and for queries.
The values are listed up there.
But what that means
is that you can go in
and you can start
using the program
today without incurring
costs, assuming
you're below these values.
So how can it support
open data use?
We have a few very
general profiles up here.
So the first one is businesses.
I've talked to
several businesses
who have told us that they
exist because the public data is
in GCP.
And what it allows
them to do is it allows
them to focus on their idea.
They don't have to focus
on building data access
mechanisms.
They don't have to focus on
maintaining these data access
mechanisms or storing them.
They can focus on
building their product
and delivering their
product to their users.
And they can do so on top
of these public datasets,
either by joining with their
proprietary data, which
we think is a really
valuable way to use it,
or by building their
product on top of the data
to deliver new
insights to users.
For researchers, you can
join multiple public datasets
together to do an
analysis in ways that
have never been done before.
One of the things
that really excites me
is the ability to
bring data together
that has previously
lived in silos that
aren't even on the same
farm, if we're going
to stick with the silo analogy.
So you're looking at data that
has just never been brought
together before, or has
not been brought together
in such an easy-to-use
format before, that
can be joined together to
find some new insights.
And then for data providers,
you can provide fast and simple
access to your
data without having
to scale your on-prem services.
So your storage scales
to a million users
or to one user for
the same effort.
So without further
introduction, Felipe.
FELIPE HOFFA: Hello, hello.
Can you hear me?
Thank you.
Thank you, Shane.
So I'm Felipe Hoffa,
and Shane gave me
this time to talk about
issues that matter to me.
Last year, I showed space
versus tabs on code,
but today I want to
speak about a real issue.
People are fighting on
the internet about this.
Where do we put our commas?
And I'm talking about SQL.
Who knows SQL here?
Excellent.
So SQL is awesome.
It's a language
invented in 1978.
We still use it.
We still love it.
You might have learned SQL
with a query like this.
SELECT name.
FROM employees.
WHERE-- they come
from some state.
Then you will want to
get more columns there,
and then you add a
third column, and then
suddenly, things don't work.
Why?
Because I have this hanging
comma here, and this
is because language creators
decided that you could not
put a comma there.
Every other modern language
will allow a comma,
but SQL will not.
So now, people are in two camps.
Some people put their
comments at the end.
commas at the start.
Who puts their
commas at the end?
commas at the start?
Two, three, four-- that's super
raggedly, but that's what I do,
too.
It's much more
efficient for me if I
put my commas at the start,
given the language limitation.
So now the question
is, can I use
data to prove to
everyone else that this
is what you should do?
So trailing commas,
leading commas.
We are Google.
We have Google Cloud.
We have BigQuery.
We have data that everyone
can see, share, and analyze.
I will look at Github just
to count the number of events
that we had on Github last year.
Give me three seconds.
Five, four-- 300 million events.
I can go further.
I can count, for example,
the number of distinct users.
And I can look at where
are they coming from?
What are the most
important countries here?
The most developers come from
null country, then the US, then
China, India.
But that's not a fair ranking.
I should do it per capita.
So who has more
programmers per capita?
It turns out it's
Iceland, Sweden, Norway--
cold countries.
Now, is it true that it's
cold countries or not?
I also have NOAA data.
I have weather data.
So if I take, on one hand,
my programmers per capita,
I take the average
weather of each country,
I can get to a chart like this
that shows that, yeah, there
is a correlation.
People in cold countries
have a higher concentration
of programmers.
Warmer countries-- lower
concentration of programmers.
Except Singapore there,
because they have very good AC,
so programmers
prefer to say inside.
Real query.
So let's go back to this issue.
Let's use-- also we have
Github calls inside the query.
And I am able to analyze,
are people using more commas
at the end or at the beginning?
This is my query.
And the results show
that way more people
use a comma at the end.
But this is not really
what I want to know.
I don't want to know
what's more popular.
I want to know what projects
are more successful.
And how do you measure success?
A larger number of stars?
Stars last year?
The number of
contributors, activity?
So I can write a bigger query
that looks for all of these,
and turns out that
these are my results.
And projects that allow
people to use leading commas
are double as successful
as the other projects.
So yes, we win.
Excellent.
And yes, BigQuery connects
to all these tools,
and you will be able to
use open data to share.
Even if these
fights do not stop,
at least you can embrace
data when going through them.
I want to show you a couple
of more features that are new,
and I'm super
excited about them.
Have you heard
about Data Studio?
Yes, so with Data
Studio now, I'm
able to take my
BigQuery analysis,
and I can create
interactive visualizations.
I recently created this
one for Stack Overflow,
and I can embed
my visualizations
in the middle of my blog post.
I can make them interactive.
These are the trends
on Stack Overflow.
Let's look, for
example, Angular.js, one
of the top tags on this site.
Angular.js is going up or down?
Down.
Why is Angular.js going down?
Because they replaced it with
a new tag that is Angular.
So whatever technology
you are interested in,
people can come, play
here, and use public data.
On the satellite side,
this is outside BigQuery.
My friend [? Lac, ?] who is
a great friend of everyone
that knows about machine
learning and weather
forecasting.
He created this great sample
looking at hurricanes.
We have in BigQuery at
least of all the hurricanes,
you can see what's happening.
So we don't know when
it's the next one,
but we know all
the previous ones.
You can use it to
get their data,
and then you can find the
files, the satellite images,
that correspond to those
hurricanes that [INAUDIBLE],,
and finally can produce--
get individual images,
create animations,
and look at what is happening
all around the world
with just some
few lines of code.
That's the power of having
the public datasets available.
And the last thing I want
to show for everyone that
is a fan of BigQuery and
has seen my Wikipedia
demo, for example,
in this demo, I'm
going to process 377
gigabytes of data
that I'm going through
billions of page views
that Wikipedia has in a month.
When I run this
query, I just want
the sum of views for Google.
This query is processing
377 gigabytes, which
is an awesome demo, but since
you have one free terabyte
every month, you
would be able only
to run three of these queries.
So good as a demo, but not
so good for public data.
And the best news we
got, for me, this--
yesterday, is that now
we can cluster tables.
We can run-- we can
set data together.
So now, when I run my query
over this new table, same query,
same amount of data, same--
we think it will
process 375 gigabytes.
Instead, it's only went
over 18 gigabytes of data.
So we are taking our poly
datasets program now.
We are going to
cluster all tables
and make it way more effective.
So yes, [INAUDIBLE],,
I'm looking at you.
[INAUDIBLE] we're going
to make these tables
all time partitioned and
clustered by the [INAUDIBLE]..
And with that, let me welcome
Shane back to take it over.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SHANE GLASS: Thanks, Felipe.
In the interest of
full disclosure,
I didn't start
using leading commas
until I saw Felipe's slides
and realized how wrong I was.
Now, I did see in
Felipe's demo, however,
that there are people who are
using both leading and trailing
commas, and those people just
want to watch the world burn.
I'm terrified of you.
You're monsters.
So next up, we have Ed
Kearns here from NOAA.
Ed is NOAA's chief data officer.
He's the first chief
data officer of NOAA,
and he's been a
great collaborator
of the public dataset program.
And I'm looking forward
to hearing from him.
[APPLAUSE]
ED KEARNS: Thank you very much.
So you wonder why there's a
government employee up here
talking at Google, but
we have this partnership
that I'm going to describe.
And you've seen the results
of this partnership.
It's very, very powerful.
So one of the things that I do
as NOAA's chief data officer,
I'm trying to find the maximum
exploitation of the taxpayer's
dollar that you've paid for
these expensive satellites.
You've paid for a lot
of collection systems
that bring data from the
environment into NOAA,
and we use that for our mission.
But we also realize there's a
secondary use for this data.
So we're using it for
managing fisheries.
We're using it for
weather forecasts.
managing our ecosystems
along the coastlines.
But we understand that you, as
maybe a small business owner,
can also use this public
open data for other purposes.
And we understand
there's value there,
and we want to
maximize that value.
And so, like I said,
we have our mission,
but the secondary use is,
how can we maximize this?
This started about
four years ago.
We realized, well, we
don't have the resources
within the federal government
to fully exploit the data.
But hey, Google does.
And can we find a way
that we can work together
in a partnership
to actually bring
that value forward and
democratize the data,
as Shane was mentioning?
So let me first explain
how big NOAA is.
So we're a fairly
big organization.
We have a very
wide scope of what
we do for the American public.
We have about 12,000 people.
Of those 12,000 people,
we've got 7,000 scientists.
And all those scientists
work with data every day.
They are oceanographers,
like I am.
They're meteorologists.
They're biologists.
They're fisheries experts.
Every single one of them
is also a data scientist
in their realm of expertise,
because data is the heartblood
of our organization.
Nothing happens in NOAA--
none of these products get out
for the American people--
without data flowing
through them.
I also have an
enormous challenge
if I want to share this data.
So at any given day, we've
got about 200 petabytes
of data residing across
NOAA's federal systems.
These are not in
the cloud, largely.
These are within-- behind
firewalls on federal systems
across the United States.
We got about 70,000 datasets,
so that's an enormous number
to try to understand.
If you just go out on
the regular internet,
and you try to find
all these datasets,
and they are almost--
probably 95% of these
are publicly available
today in an open fashion
if you can find where they are.
And so that's the challenge.
We've got 1,200
registered web domains.
We got 240,000
individual websites
that are out there
that all have data.
So it's very hard for you
all to find and consume
the data that we have.
But we try to find
different ways of doing it.
And we're trying to
embrace the cloud,
trying to bring new
technologies in.
Last year, we did use
the cloud in order
to try to make
sure everybody that
needed hurricane data, hurricane
forecast data, before Hurricane
Irma hit Florida, that
they had access to it.
And last year,
yes, indeed, we're
getting a billion hits a day.
And because we're using
cloud technologies
in front of our
federal services,
we're able to do that,
so a great success story.
But we are also usually the
number two or number three
website in all of the
United States government
because so many people
need our data every day.
So in order to use this
data, there's two challenges.
One is technical.
How do you get the data?
And the example that
Felipe just showed
that [? Lac ?] had
put together really
shows how working with
Google has simplified this,
because before
that, if you wanted
to work with our satellite data
and work with our hurricane
data, you had to download
all of these different things
back to your own
local computer site,
or wherever it might be, and
then try to do things with it.
What this example showed is
you can do everything in place.
So some of our datasets
or climate models
are about a petabyte in size.
It's really hard even
to move that data
within our own organization,
much less get it out to you
so you can use it.
So these are some of the
technical challenges.
But the bigger challenge
that we're trying to fix
is the understanding,
to try to figure out
what these data mean,
and how to convey
that understanding to you.
So I've got 7,000
scientists that
know exactly what
those data mean,
but how do they interact with
you to convey the meaning?
Because like I said, we've
got the data parked out there
already.
We've had the data parked
out there for many years,
and it's not getting picked
up and used in the kind of way
that it is being used when
we're seeing we put it
on Google Cloud Platform.
And that's what we're
trying to learn more about.
So what we did four
years ago is we
signed what's called
a Cooperative Research
and Development
Agreement, or a CRADA.
It's a government
term, but it's a way
of actually having an experiment
going on with industry where
there's no money exchanged,
but where we have agreed
to work on a common problem.
And we've been doing this
for four years with Google
right now.
So this comes at no
cost to the taxpayer.
The trick here is that
these data are open.
Data that remain open.
Google is not selling the data.
They're selling
services around the data
so they can recoup
their investment,
but they are hosting the
taxpayers' data from NOAA
for free.
And so we understand
how that can scale,
and you just saw examples of
this, of how the clouds can
scale and the open
data can scale,
the availability can scale.
But to really get
over the hurdle,
we're focused on the
expertise, because I
can park a lot of this
complicated data out there
and you still won't know
exactly how to use it.
So we have to solve this.
So you heard about
some of the examples
with some of the
successes already.
The sweet spot that we found,
instead of just parking
the data out there, if we're
loading the data into the tools
that people are already using--
and BigQuery is a perfect
example of this--
by loading NOAA's weather
data into BigQuery,
people can come and use that
data, join on that data,
consume that data.
They don't have to break down
a complicated scientific data
format.
They don't have to try to
understand what all these mean.
They understand, hey, it's
temperature, precipitation,
it's cloudiness, it's wind.
They understand what it is.
It's already loaded into
tools they're using.
They can immediately
consume it and use it.
That's a very exciting
paradigm, and so we're trying
to see how we leverage this.
So we're comparing an A/B test--
how is this working on Google
versus how it's working
from our own federal servers?
And we're seeing
at least 10 times--
probably between 10 and
100 times more consumption
of these weather data coming
out of BigQuery than we're
seeing from our own
internal services right now.
And this came--
when we first did--
when we first started this
about a year ago now, I guess,
when we first got
this off the ground,
one of the interesting things
is we didn't advertise it.
NOAA didn't advertise the
availability of these weather
data in BigQuery yet.
Google did not advertise it yet.
They were still thinking about
how they were going to proceed.
But while we're talking about
what we're going to do next,
users of BigQuery came in
and found the data anyways,
and they started to consume it.
It required no advertising.
We didn't have to put
out any press release
that these data were available.
People were just able
to find and use it,
and that's a great story.
Being able to combine
datasets-- and the example
that Felipe showed
with the hurricanes
that [? Lac ?] put
together, because again,
just a great example
of bringing multiple
datasets together that
otherwise may be hard to do,
but when they're all in the
same place on the same cloud,
it becomes really trivial.
And so where are we
going with this, too?
So we're trying to
find-- there's increasing
levels of usage for our data.
We're trying to make sure
you, the data consumer,
can get the data more quickly.
We have our archive system.
We have 30 petabytes
in our archive.
It is still a
tape-based archive.
The archive is
primarily preservation,
but we make all those data open.
It is very hard to get 30
petabytes out of a tape
archive, as you all know.
However, if those data
are sitting on the cloud,
it's fairly trivial.
And so we're looking
at ways that we
can continue to raise that level
of service and do so in a way
that the taxpayer
is not burdened.
So we're trying to leverage
that value that's in the data,
the value to Google's
users, Google's customers,
trying to leverage
that value to enable
this new way of providing
access to federal data.
And so we've been doing
this for four years--
well, a little over three years.
It will be four years
when we're done.
But we're really trying to say,
how can we do this sustainably?
So we're doing this
experimentally right now.
We're excited about the results.
But how do we take
this to the next level?
And I really need to
hear from you all.
The federal government
needs to hear,
is this something that you like?
Do you like to get
NOAA's federal data
on the Google Cloud?
If you find this valuable,
we need to hear about it.
We need to be able to--
as we're going to our next
level of discussions with Google
about how can this work,
how can this partnership
work sustainably, going on for
many years into the future?
Because NOAA's bringing
the expertise to the table.
So that's what-- we're not
just bringing the data,
we're bringing the expertise,
and Google's bringing
their infrastructure.
How do we maintain that
business relationship?
We found, and Google's
found it very valuable
to be able to have those
discussions with NOAA experts,
to literally do the
deep dive on ocean data,
to actually have those
one-on-one discussions
and be able to turn that
around and figure out,
how do those products
fit into the Google tools
and meet the demands
of their users?
So we're looking
for that right now.
There's also a federal
data strategy effort
that has just begun, as well.
And if you go to
strategy.data.gov,
we're in an open
public comment period
right now, where the federal
government is asking the data
users across the
country, what do you
want to see with federal data?
Do you like things like
this kind of partnership
with industry that
allow federal data to be
available on the cloud?
Or would you rather pick it
up from a federal service?
These are real questions that
we're dealing with right now.
The timing is fantastic,
but honestly, this
is a time that we need
to hear your voice.
If you go to
BigQuery, and you've
been experimenting with
these public datasets,
if this resonates with you,
there's a time right now
to be able to speak up
and be heard and have
this kind of partnership,
this cloud-based data access,
baked into how the federal
data strategy is going
to be rolling into the future.
And timing is
everything in life.
And so this CRADA came
along at the perfect time.
The results have come along,
again, just in the nick of time
so that these things can be
integrated into the wider
strategy.
And yeah, please, please--
I welcome, if you
want to drop me
an email at this
email address, or you
want to go and
turn your comments
in at strategy.data.gov,
I encourage
you to do so and
welcome your feedback.
And I think I'm turning it
back over to Shane, now.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, thanks, Ed.
And I think Ed touched
on something big,
and there's the example
of it here on this slide.
So in case you haven't heard
enough about [? Lac's ?] demo,
we've got a little
bit more here for you.
But I think that one
of the things that's--
I think this is a true
big data application.
And big data is one of
those buzzwords that
is used to mean everything,
and as a result,
it really means nothing
because it's just used broadly,
it doesn't really have
a meaning these days.
But I think this is really
a big data application.
Now, data is the new oil.
We've all heard that.
This is not an original
thought that Shane just had.
But I've kind of thought
about this phrase a lot.
I've kind of gone
back and forth on it,
and I think that my opinion
on that phrase is sort of.
Data's sort of the new oil.
And I think that
the analogy is--
it's imperfect, but I think
it has some value in that data
in its rawest form has value.
So having raw oil, just like
having raw data, yes, that
has some value.
But being able to process
that data, to convert it
into insights, into
information, just
like being able to process oil
into gasoline, into plastics,
that is really where
the valuable application
of this product is.
And that's what we're trying
to unlock for our users.
So what you see on the left is
a sample of the BigQuery table
that [? Lac ?] used
for his demonstration
on visualizing the imagery
from Hurricane Maria.
And so what that is,
is it's called IBTrACS.
There's a very
long acronym there,
but it's essentially the
international community
coming together and
saying, we agree
that at this place and
time, this hurricane
was at this place.
It is a shockingly difficult
thing to come to agreement on.
But what we've found is that,
that doesn't always line up.
It's not always associated
with the satellite imagery
that you see on the right there.
And what we found was that those
are in such different places,
they're in such
disparate locations,
that they're very
rarely combined.
Moreover, while the data
on the left are in CSV,
or available in CSV, the data
on the right are in netCDF4.
Is anybody familiar
with the netCDF4 file
format that is not employed
by the federal government?
Yeah, so we have a
handful of people,
which is a handful more--
we have a handful of people,
which is a handful more
than I expected.
So netCDF4 is great for
the scientific community
because it does--
it compresses very well, and
it does a lot of other things
very well.
But it's not-- but it's
very, very specific
to the scientific community.
The general data science
community, the data scientists
out there, as opposed to
the environmental scientists
out there, aren't
used to using this.
So that's a barrier to entry.
You have to go out.
You have to find these data.
You have to find the
Python library for it.
You have to find out how to
use the Python library for it.
You have to find out where to
find out how to use the Python
library for it.
You have to go back.
You have to write
your Python for it.
You have to go eat dinner
because at this point,
it's already been all day.
And then maybe you
can get an analysis
unless you're working
for the government.
But what we can do here is we
can lower that barrier to entry
by putting the data from
IBTrACS in BigQuery.
It's now a SQL
query away, and we
can subsample by, in this
case, by hurricane name.
And we can take that
very easily on the right,
and we can associate that
with the same center points
from the satellite imagery
that has the hurricane.
And now you can go from
data to insights faster.
You can go from oil
to gasoline faster.
You can get the value out of
your data as soon as you can,
as opposed to having to wait
and go through this process.
We've worked very
hard to eliminate
all those barriers that entry.
Now, this slide was made before
the announcement was made.
However, BigQuery launched
their GeoViz capability,
their geovisualization
capability, this week.
And that takes us even further.
So we've talked a lot about
what we've done in the past.
You've heard a lot of
our metrics in the past.
You've heard Ed talk about the
great collaboration we've had
so far, and you've heard
Felipe talk about some
of the things that can be done
with the datasets we already
have.
And we talked a little bit
about what we want to do.
We talked about how we're
working with NOAA right now
to figure out, what's
a sustainable long-term
partnership beyond the end
of our agreement next year?
And so let's talk a little
about what we're going to do.
So this is a look at
our mission and vision
statement for the program
going into next year.
So our mission is to
maximize the availability
and accessibility of
flagship public datasets
in Google Cloud.
We're looking at things
like large, large scale
datasets that are putting
such a burden on our providers
that they have to limit the
access available to them
now in order to protect their
systems from being brought down
and overwhelmed.
And our vision here is to
enable the development,
and to leverage collaborations,
with key public dataset
providers like NOAA built
around on high impact verticals.
And so the goal here is to
take these weather datasets
and not just make them
available to the meteorologists
of the world, but to
make them available to
the entire community for use.
And let's see what cool
stuff comes out of it.
Let's see what people
are able to learn.
are able to build
for themselves going forward.
So looking at the way ahead,
we're really, really excited
about the launch
of BigQuery on ML.
It allows you to build
regression models and cluster
analyses, among other things,
on top of your datasets.
And we think that this helps
you create the only machine
learning ready public dataset
program available today.
All you have to
do to use machine
learning on top of BigQuery
public datasets today
is go write SQL.
You don't have to-- yes,
you have to clean your data.
And unfortunately, no,
I know very few people
who like to clean data.
But you don't have to find it.
You don't discover it.
You don't have to move it.
You don't have to
learn TensorFlow.
TensorFlow's great, but you
don't have to learn TensorFlow.
You can just write
your analysis,
and you can just get started.
The BigQuery
geovisualization capability,
we're really excited
about that in combination
with the second point
of the slide, which
is utility datasets.
So what we're focused
on going forward
is enabling our partners, like
NOAA, to onboard the datasets
into our program.
Now, does that mean
that Google's never
going to onboard and
curate datasets again?
No, what it means
is that we're going
to continue our
focus on datasets
that are more broadly
used across all domains.
So we have a group
of datasets that we
call the utility datasets.
They're just things
that we generally
find useful for all users or
for large swaths of users,
regardless of what
their interests are.
One of these datasets
that's available today
is zip code areas, so it gives
you your five digit zip code,
the town associated with
it, and a few other metrics.
What we've added to it
recently is the polygon
associated with
that zip code area
from the Census
Bureau's website.
So you could take
today, and you could
visualize, by zip
code, your data
and take it out to the BigQuery
geovisualization capability,
and you could visualize
your data today.
We're hoping to have a
demonstration of that
and a walkthrough query for
that launched very soon.
But that capability
is available today,
as was announced earlier.
And so our focus is going to
be on providing these datasets
that we just generally
hear across the community
that people need, and allow our
partners and their expertise
to scale out on our platform
to reduce that burden for them.
So I'm really proud to announce
that, in support of this,
we are making a five
petabytes commitment
to public datasets in BigQuery.
My personal take is that this
is an unmatched commitment
in the community right now.
We're making five petabytes
of BigQuery storage
available to host public
datasets going forward.
And that's great, and that's
a ton of structured data.
But what good does it
do to store data if--
to extract and store data if
it's going to be gone tomorrow?
And we hear this concern a
lot with our public dataset
providers that we
collaborate with.
Why should I invest my
effort, my team's effort,
into uploading the data if
it's going to be gone tomorrow?
And because of
that, we're really
proud to announce that, in
addition to this five petabytes
commitment, we are making this
commitment for five years.
So this five petabytes
will be available each year
for the next five years
to host public datasets
in Google BigQuery.
We're really excited
about this, and I
think this is going
to enable us to do
some really great
things in collaboration
with our partners.
So obviously, you wanted
to get started today,
because Felipe, Ed,
and I have gotten
you so excited about Google's
public dataset program.
I did not see any eyes rolling.
That's good.
So if you want to
use public datasets,
I encourage you to go to
these sites right here.
That's cloud.google.com
/bigquery/publicdata
or cloud.google.com/public
datasets.
On here, you'll find some
descriptions and some overviews
of some of the datasets we have,
as well as some connections out
to sample queries.
If they're good,
they're written by me.
If not, they're
written by Felipe.
That's obviously the way
that that would work.
And so you can connect out.
And I think that's a
really great way to just
get started immediately.
You don't have to know
everything about the dataset,
but you can get an idea for what
the structure of the data are
and for how to use them and
then kind of build from there.
So you don't have to
build from scratch.
Do you have public data?
I want to be friends with you.
If you have public data,
you can get started today.
You can go to
BigQuery or you can
go to Google Cloud
Storage and leverage
the free tier of storage that
we talked about earlier today.
So if you're under 10
gigabytes a month for BigQuery,
you can go in today.
You can store that, and
you can make it public,
and you can share
it with anybody.
And because of the
way BigQuery bills,
it's the person running the
query that is billed for that,
so you aren't billed for that.
Same thing with
Google Cloud Storage.
I just obviously
have a note there
that before you share
it with other people,
unless you want
to pay the costs,
I would put it on a requester
pays mechanism for that.
So I think I'm safe on that one.
So maybe you're over the
free tier of storage.
Maybe you have a ton of public
data, and that's even better.
I want to be even
better friends with you.
Feel free to reach out to us
at gcp-public-data@google.com.
That goes to myself.
That goes to a couple of other
of our team members as well,
and we'd love to get started
working with you on hosting
public data.
So thank you so much,
everybody, for coming out.
Let's have a round of applause
for Felipe and for Ed.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]